imagine do you enter these new vertel
body that you look down and your hands
are these saw their hands they move as
you move
perfectly only you're a different race
or a different gender so you can
experience the life perspective of a
different person from within you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen Hughes anga today
we're here with nerves scientists and
Microsoft researcher dr. Morgan Salas
Franco she'll discuss her research in
virtual reality the importance of
avatars and she'll clear up the
misconceptions between VR and
psychedelic drugs that and much more on
this episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast mar you have a really
interesting background how did you end
up doing research at Microsoft I think
in life they're sort of cycles that you
end up doing the same thing again like I
started trained as a computer scientist
mathematician and then I became very
interested time your neuroscience and
then I came back to computer science so
it kind of comes together I would say
there is always not a single route to
get somewhere and definitely you need to
take it step by step so I wouldn't be
here if I didn't do my PhD with Mel
Slater and partially at the MIT for sure
I mean these Microsoft Research really
Scouts for talent in in the wide
spectrum on a global scale and you have
to be there and there is a part of being
lucky to be in a very hot spot that is
of interest to the company in a very
specific moment you told me that VR can
trick the brain yeah and that people
know it's fake but they have a strong
experience of reality anyway
so what's good about that and what's bad
about that and what do we take away from
that it kind of scares me but it's kind
of cool so yeah it's very interesting
because we are providing a real-time
stream of information to our senses
mainly beer the reality has been based
on this one and humans are very visual
animals we believe what we see and
virtual reality provides that it
provides a congruent sensory motor a
stimulation one of the experiments I did
you put on some sort of glasses and hmd
with virtual reality you put your hand
on top of a table and you see a little
hand instead of your hand and that hand
gets attacked and what I find is that
the motor cortex gets activated in the
same way that it would be activated for
a real attack to your real hand so you
really perceive this is your hand and I
think this is very interesting because
it means not only that you can enter a
virtual reality you can change your body
in that reality so what are the
implications of what you just said in
terms of application outside the fact
that you've observed that you can make
people believe that a virtual hand is
actually their hand some very
interesting applications have to do with
empathy imagined you enter these new
virtual body that you look down and your
hands are these saw their hands they
move as you move
perfectly only you're a different race
or a different gender so you can
experience the life perspective of a
different person from within
philosophers and psychologists have
explored this role playing
this is role playing to the maximum
exponential you're basically within a
different body you're talking about
avatars now yeah there it's just a hand
avatar or a full-body avatar and that's
the main component of virtual reality
I think avatars are becoming more
than ever with virtual reality we
experience reality and people experience
ourselves through our bodies and so it's
very easy to evaluate things from the
perspective of our own body and invert
the reality we need to have a body an
avatar that represent us so if we can
have realistic experiences through
avatars what are the things might we be
able to do through VR how how else might
it help us this is a very important
topic in my research the avatar that you
embody if you embody an avatar that is
of a different race you can reduce your
racial bias and this is some experiments
that have already been done there are
other experiments that have shown that
if you embody an avatar that is older so
it looks like you it's a look-alike
avatar just a little bit older your
financial decisions after you come out
become more conservative you're more
likely to save money and not only these
even more traditional fears like fear of
heights fear of flying brutal reality
provides of a very controlled platform
to perform therapy interventions and
then during an intervention people might
develop a crisis and you might want to
take them out invert the reality it's
simply a headset you remove it your
inner plane you're out from there an
airplane if you want to treat somebody
who's a fear of flight has this problem
by putting them inside a real plane and
flying them to New York they might
develop the crisis in the middle of
their flight and there is no way for you
to stop it so in that scenario is much
more secure so for anybody who's
treating this kind of phobias virtual
reality is clearly a very good option
so is this happening already or is this
just something
that you're looking at one of the
possible applications for VR in the
future no people are already using it of
course there are only few people that
have this really really extreme phobias
that cannot be treated in a less
immersive way like you could treat your
phobias by going in the real world and
rather than in the brittle ball but it
also allows you to treat your phobias
from home you have a device at home you
don't need to go to a center to be
exposed to these therapies so he'd also
democratize a lot these sort of
treatments or interventions let's talk
about the illusory nature of VR for a
bit I read an article where the headline
said and I quote microsoft says virtual
reality could make you hallucinate in
the same way as LSD that was a rather
sensational version of what you actually
said I think but can you talk a bit
about how your work in VR is like and
even unlike hallucinogenic drugs when
Jaron Lanier started the first brutal
reality company he was faced all the
time like how is going to be like an LSD
trip and of course the answer is not but
I'm gonna go a bit more on detail
because I I do think it's legitimate for
people to be concerned about how a
technology is gonna affect their life so
virtual reality in the best form
provides a very strong illusory set up
to create illusions illusion such as
there is a glass on top of this table
but in reality there is not such thing
when the reality has the same power but
this is an illusion in which you never
lose your higher cognitive functioning
there is no chemical alteration of your
brain it's purely sensorial you're
seeing this glass of water it looks so
realistic and you move around and the
glass is staying there so at the end it
really feels like there is something
there and but you think of the glasses
and there is nothing there compared to
two drugs this person has never lost
their higher cognitive function during
this illusory State and that change is
completely the topic because higher
cognitive function is the one that
allows you to make conscious decisions
decision-making processes what right
what's wrong and because that's never
altered you're always aware that this is
not real versus when people do drugs
that's completely lost so I would say
that these are very two different ways
of experiencing reality
you're really interested in the societal
impacts of virtual reality so what are
the best things about your work in VR
first of all these democratization of
the technology arrive in people who have
never been able to own any previous
technological advancement and now all of
a sudden they have something that
includes them all no it's like one ring
to rule them all and I'm in the reality
inverter reality are getting there in
fact there is still a bit the fight on
whether it's gonna take the form of a
phone that you put on on top or it's
going to be a completely new device that
you can render a phone in it but it's
true that it's going to be mobile in the
sense that the battery it's going to be
there and you're going to put it on and
render from first person perspective and
so that's very exciting
because it's gonna have very big
implications on society it's going to
change many things of how we live give
me an example of what you think that
might be like one thing that could help
us yeah I think in particular this
tendency we have to buy so many gadgets
that may actually go away and we have
one single gadget this has not happened
with any other device even we have
tablets now we still have a laptop or we
work on a desktop if we're talking about
device that is going to be able to embed
them all you're really going to not have
a desktop afterwards you're just going
to have this device so that's because
you can render on a computer in it or
you can render a tablet or you can
render everything
explain to me render how does that work
territorial in virtual reality you have
a display an ear I display because it's
like a glass so inside these glasses
you digitally print an image just like
you would do in a regular screen it's
just that this screen it's always
available for you so inside this screen
you can print different things printing
inverter in in digital is usually
referred as rendering what I hear you
talking about is like a Google glass
kind of it's it's very different because
Google glass was an annotation device it
would provide you information on the top
which is not blended with reality this
is not an annotation technique this is
very different technological system and
this is with current hololens I can only
imagine when we move forward is
something more like instead of having a
computer at home or a TV I have my
glasses know that this this wall has a
TV on it and when I come home the TV is
dinner you know I don't need to put it
back but you're looking through a device
you're looking through a device like
glasses normal glasses so does everyone
in your family have to have them feel
like you have a family of five everyone
has to have the glasses in order to see
the TV the virtual team we're working on
these because it's interesting to
explore what each person will see
because also using this glasses I could
do something very unique right which is
seeing what you're seeing if we're
sending one in front of each other and
we have tart in front of us you're
seeing one perspective of the tart and
I'm seeing another one what if we both
could see exactly the same thing despite
being on different precision so I mean
we start a very interesting topic of
perspective Wow my mind is just reeling
with what you're talking about and
trying to imagine because my paradigms
are so right now
right my my way of writing is using a
keyboard and a screen but you're
suggesting a whole new paradigm that we
don't even if we're doing well enough
you will have to change nothing from
your current interaction techniques they
will be embedded in the new technology
let me just extrapolate here I could
have a device on and render a keyboard
yep you will take your pen physical pen
the pen will be recognized by these
glasses and you'll bright on a digital
notebook this is so sci-fi science
fiction is a very good inspiration for
science
what's the biggest limitation you face
right now you're sitting in Redmond
doing research and if you could say hey
this would make my life way easier what
I'm trying to figure out here well what
kinds of things are impeding your
progress I think Microsoft is very good
at they're giving all the resources you
need to do whatever you want to do of
course you have to deliver but that's
like in every other job so I don't think
I have many I would say is time I don't
have time to do everything I want but
these sounds are good because it gives
you the unique opportunity to focus you
need to focus and you need to big fights
that you want the most important ones
and you actually said at one point that
virtual reality can prove neuroscience
yes so there there are some theories
that are only available because they
have explored very particular
pathologies that happen very rarely in
the normal population maybe one of our
million people have something like that
maybe it's something related to epilepsy
removal of an epilepsy center that has
detached your frontal lobe from the
motor cortex for example so this is very
unique scenarios and and they're people
who undergo this pathology of the
anarchic hand illusion which they cannot
control their hand at will they know is
their hand but they cannot control it
and this is a real thing in real life
yes anarchic hand
yeah it's of one hand yes but it's like
simple things like you're eating a
sandwich I'm hungry my hand knows I'm
hungry
it picks your sandwich so these people
learn to because the other hand usually
is fully functional
learn to hold their hand so they just
hold themselves so they keep it from
grabbing my sandwich yes for example is
that for real
Jesus this is Ariana pathology ok but
this is a case study type of thing okay
if you wanna develop a real model of
these you might want to try to produce
the same kind of illusion on healthy
individuals and then you can see what
happens in the brain when this happens
and then compare it to what happens to a
person who has this real path ology of
course these healthy participants once
they go out from VR they are perfectly
well they don't have any issue on their
control of their body just like when
they interview the reality they can not
control their body as they as they wish
but the point would be to see what
comparisons you could make in a healthy
brain versus an unhealthy brain and how
that might be able to treat yes and also
to understand how the brain works in
general for both healthy and healthy so
there are two mechanisms in the brain
that we used to control our experiences
so the first one is a bottom-up it's
purely sensorial whatever we feel we
touch we see we integrated in a
multi-sensory way and that's how we
define reality the other one is we have
predictions and sometimes they're very
strong for example when we feel the
phone vibrates and it didn't this is a
top-down illusion other people
experience that too besides me
yes I'm not kidding yeah it's called a
phantom phone yeah yes yeah yeah so
these experience is very sensorial you
would swear that you felt it this is how
powerful our brain is into manipulating
our sensory input and the interesting
thing about the phantom phone is that we
become aware of it but there are
millions of predictions that are being
rejected without even us being
consciously aware of it Wow
so in virtual reality we can kind of
heart separate in both and seeing how
they work one with the other and it's
very interesting because this when you
play with these you learn a lot about
the neuroscience on things that are very
hard to test in reality so I think
vertel reality is definitely a tool for
neuroscience so let's say that you're
this generation of virtual reality and
neuroscience exploration if you will
what's on the horizon for students
coming out of university now we have
both in the US and in Europe very
important big projects there is the
brain project in the US and a human
brain project in Europe both of them
with over a billion dollar funding which
is huge
they are mobilizing a whole community to
finally get to understand the brain and
still we don't know it and certainly
even the people who are doing AI are
very interested on understanding because
if you want to simulate something you
need to know how it works what would you
like people to know about the research
you're doing I think in general one of
the things from a researcher perspective
that is different from a product
developer perspective is the outreach so
the fact that we can communicate that
you can do this type of things or you
could use technology to explore your
science can improve dramatically a whole
community of science so how from one
science you can transfer to another so
you you are kind of becoming that bridge
I think when we work in research we can
transfer something show that is useful
for something else and then empower
whole community into using it in a
different way how does doing research at
Microsoft differ from doing research at
say a university or another academic
setting the way Microsoft Research moves
is very fast compared to academic
research so for me to pursue an idea I
need to convince my BP
so I need to pitch it I have to think
about it but I don't need to bribed a
grant and then ask this very big
organization of grant founding to
evaluate it and so it's much faster so
my ability to reach to people and to
collaborate with them it's incredible
and I love it
just as we as we go just say one quick
thing about what's what you're the most
passionate about right now in your work
I mean aside from your you know I'm very
interested about producing tactile
sensations out of the body I know this
sounds very weird but I am creating this
system in which you're holding a virtual
object and you feel the burden object
being touched but not directly on your
hands you know somewhere else it's kind
of difficult to explain it here but this
would mean that we can perceived touch
in a similar way that we're perceiving
audio and this is I'm working with a
Christopher burger on this his Caltech
and we're both super excited about it
and this has been my work during the
summer and this has a lot to do with
haptics so if you have very simple
Bieber activator in your hands and
you're able to perceive touch across the
space that's even better what you can do
in reality Marv you are fascinating
absolutely fascinating I want to have
happy hour with you for real good
anything
[Music]
to learn more about virtual reality and
dr. mark and solace Franco and the
latest in Microsoft Research explore our
website at Microsoft comm slash research
[Music]